well it's official YouTube has just now
banned anything related to health that
doesn't align with the General Medical
consensus so if any information related
to health doesn't agree with the World
Health Organization they won't
necessarily always take down the the
video but they're going to change the
algorithms so they're going to replace
those videos that were popular that had
lots of likes and lots of Engagement
with medical information this new
partnership with YouTube is supposed to
protect you against misinformation and
promote high quality health information
and their definition of misinformation
is anything that opposes their Viewpoint
I mean if you go to drberg.com you will
see that I have
7607 success stories I'm helping people
I'm giving people lots of non-toxic
Solutions and if you just read the
comments you'll see that a lot of people
are being helped so my information is
not dangerous it's not misinformation
it's actually quite helpful and this new
change is going to hurt a lot of people
because they're not going to be able to
find alternative viewpoints alternative
opinions sometimes medicine doesn't work
you know looking for inexpensive natural
remedies to handle certain body issues
but guess what now they're going to have
a very difficult time finding those
Solutions because all these medical
sites are going to replace Alternative
Health I mean I used to rank for so many
conditions now you can't even find me
unless you type Dr Berg slash whatever
and even on the keto diet I have
928 keto videos that's right 928 videos
guess what when you type keto diet you
can't find me instead the number one
ranked video is from Mayo Clinic okay
and the comments are turned off and you
can see the likes are actually not very
high compared to the number of views I
think they have like 260 000 views but
very few likes and it's an anti-keto
video and I'm going to share some
interesting things in that video but I
first want to communicate a couple
things you know a long time ago when
Google started they had this motto and
that was do the right thing
and then they changed it to don't be
evil
and now I don't even I don't even know
what if they have a model but you think
just giving people this one medical
Viewpoint this Monopoly over your body
your health care
you think that's going to increase the
quality of Health I mean basically this
move is going to wipe out the
competition and competition competing
viewpoints and opinions are very very
good in the healthcare field because it
forces everyone to raise the bar and do
better at getting results and how do we
trust this Medical Group with all the
Strategic alliances and the Strategic
Partners the Strategic alliances with
big Pharma and how they partner with
medical universities and medical
journals how do we trust that like I
said before their definition of
misinformation is basically any
information that opposes the medical
Viewpoint the medical consensus how do
we make sure they're transparent with
all the conflict of interest the
Strategic alliances and the Strategic
partners and what they call the
stakeholders which some of them are part
of industry and of course the revolving
doors with all the directors it's
terrible it's terrible and I think it's
going to hurt a lot of people because
freedom of health information is really
freedom of speech it's a very slippery
slope the more you start filtering out
other opinions other viewpoints
so many people go on the internet
because they have not gotten results
with certain types of medications and
they're trying to find Alternatives so
if someone wants something that's
non-toxic okay or something that's
natural or a do-it-yourself remedy that
is all considered dangerous
misinformation yeah it's just terrible
but it's not just me it's all the other
Alternative Healthcare practitioners
anyone who comments on nutrition even
the layperson who wants to share their
viewpoint on health they're not going to
rank and this doesn't just hurt me or
them it hurts the person trying to find
the right knowledge we're going to be
pretty much stuck with just one way of
treating the body and they call this
science they call this high quality
health information really and there's
also a really interesting side comment
that I read about this and they call it
the silent epidemic it's called Health
the literacy and some of these people
that are writing about this um give
Health A literacy as the reason why
people aren't going to the doctors as
much and they're going online searching
for alternative viewpoints on health and
this is what they defined Health
illiteracy
you ready for this it's an inability to
comprehend and use medical information
and they say this it's worse with the
elderly
poor people and minorities sounds a
little bit like discrimination to me so
basically they're saying that it's an
epidemic out there there's so many
people who just can't understand
medicine right and that's probably why
they're going to Alternative sites you
know like things like that and not
sticking with Incredible high quality
Health Care information I mean this is
just ridiculous I mean maybe they don't
understand it because the doctor is
talking over their head or the
information doesn't make sense or maybe
they do really understand they just
don't agree with this idea of
suppressing a symptom with a drug and
being on the drug the rest of your life
to me that's not science I mean even if
you start looking up like pretty much
almost every disease psoriasis Ms if you
look at the cause of this it'll say
unknown cause unknown cause we don't
know what causes it well if you don't
know what causes it what makes you the
expert over that condition you know but
what really frustrates me is having them
take over the keywords for the ketogenic
diet now why is that a bad thing because
they don't have any experience in that
area many times when doctors go to
school they don't get a lot of training
in nutrition or anything alternative and
so now they get to be the controllers of
that information as well this next video
that I'm going to show you is the video
ranked number one for the ketogenic diet
check this out according to Dr Google
the most searched question of 2018 was
what is the keto diet now the reason I'm
bringing this up and this was even four
years ago keto is very popular people
are searching for it the bottom line is
the more people that get on this diet
the less medication they're going to
need because it handles so many issues
instead of carbs for energy the body
burns fat entering a state called
ketosis ketosis what could go wrong
sounds like a great plan sounds a little
dangerous to me that's why I've not
tried it dangerous really
here's the problem the lack of
differentiating between
therapeutic ketosis okay or they call it
nutritional ketosis
and
ketoacidosis but mild ketosis or
therapeutic ketosis is extremely
therapeutic and I'm going to put some
links on a whole bunch of science behind
that that supports that when I think
about ketosis sometimes I get a little
nervous I think well gosh we don't
really actually want you in ketosis but
can you tell us about that right and I
think and I think this is something that
is the unknown with when when people are
saying well I'm going to put myself on a
ketogenic diet and be in ketosis because
really when you think about what ketosis
is it's it's a it's a alternative
pathway that our body has to use in
times of emergency so right there you
could see that um a huge bias they don't
want people to do keto they think
ketosis only occurs in an emergency
situation when you are starving or
something like that that is so false
talk about misinformation on steroids
that is absolutely not true do you
realize that when your body goes into
this mild ketosis your flight or
fighting mechanism goes down it reduces
cortisol
you help balance the autonomic nervous
system it's anything but emergency it's
super healthy so you're right it's it's
it's something that historically has
alarmed Us in terms of we don't
necessarily want people to be in ketosis
it can be very dangerous Ketone bodies
are considered toxic your body has uh
two two ways of getting rid of them you
you either exhale them through your
breath or you urinate them out and so it
is a stressful kind of process on your
body too because your your body is
trying to rid itself of these Ketone
bodies here's another clip that shows
that they just don't have any
information about this they have zero
information about the healthy version of
ketosis it's not toxic it's not
dangerous ketones are actually a super
fuel ketones are an antioxidant and they
talk about it being toxic because your
body's trying to get rid of it through
urine or breath yeah
that's just in the transition step when
you're transitioning over to burning fat
the motor is inefficient so you're
wasting some of these ketones and then
very quickly your body becomes very
efficient where you're utilizing all
this Ketone energy in fact a ketone is
much more efficient than glucose it
produces more energy and it runs off fat
I mean just think about way back when we
have this Hunter gather type environment
we develop this ability to to run on
ketones for a survival mechanism because
we didn't have food available we didn't
have all these carbohydrates so to say
that ketones are dangerous it's just the
opposite glucose is dangerous and toxic
in fact the numbers of people who have
diabetes
have a condition called hyperglycemia
that's high blood glucose another term
for that is glucotoxicity okay that's
very very damaging and what's really
interesting about that concept is this
when you eat a lot of sugar in carbs
okay which they don't seem to have a
problem with over time you develop
diabetes right and in an advanced type 2
diabetes as well as type 1 diabetes
that's when you can develop this
ketoacidosis problem so the number one
reason why people have ketoacidosis is
because they have high blood glucose
okay it has nothing to do with being on
a ketogenic diet I've never met one
person
that's one on the ketogenic diet and is
developed ketoacidosis
um Dr kozing you and I both said we know
people who have a lot of people yeah
lost hundreds of pounds people I know
socially or people that I um in patients
of mine and big weight loss and they
feel great well and so for them they
consider that to be finger quotes
successful yeah but possibly we're
talking two different languages here so
ketosis and those ketones and things
that is not someplace that you want to
be health-wise yes weight loss is one of
those successful indicators but what
about all the other great indicators
like the improved blood sugars like the
having less of a fatty liver better
cholesterol levels better energy better
cognitive function less inflammation
better mood these are all the benefits
of the ketogenic diet anyway I have a
personal favor I want to ask you
um I would love to get your opinion on
the situation
so if you would please
click the link down below
and go through the survey questions and
tell me what your opinion is on this
what I think is very radical recent
change of suppressing
other viewpoints on health so I want to
thank you for watching this video and
thank you in advance for filling out
this survey
because I really want to know what you
think about this